Singular: der Hund
Plural: die Hunde
Ich habe einen kleinen, süßen Hund.
Er heißt Max.
Ich habe sogar 3 süße, kleine Hunde.
Sie heißen Jimmy, Johnny und Joker.
Mein Hund Max bellt immer, wenn er hungrig ist.
Meine Hunde Jimmy, Johnny und Joker
bellen immer, wenn sie eine Katze sehen.
Hast du auch einen Hund?
Singular: das Haus
Plural: die Häuser
Das Haus ist sehr hoch.
Es ist ein sogenanntes Hochhaus.
Die Häuser in meiner Straße sehen alle gleich aus.
Sie haben dieselbe Architektur.
Das Haus hat einen wunderschönen, grünen Garten.
In vielen deutschen Großstädten
gibt es sehr viele Hochhäuser.
Wohnst du in einem Haus oder in einer Wohnung?
Singular: die Universität
Plural: die Universitäten
Jawoll! Ich wurde an der Universität angenommen!
In Deutschland gibt es viele
verschiedene Universitäten.
Die Abkürzung für Universität
lautet Uni. "Ich gehe zur Uni."
Die Chemiestudenten studieren
an der Technischen Universität.
Sie studieren an der "TU".
Kennst du auch eine deutsche Universität?
Singular: das Auto
Plural: die Autos
Das Polizeiauto fährt mit Blaulicht.
Momentan sind Elektroautos
in Deutschland sehr beliebt.
Mein Auto hat leider eine Panne.
Ich telefoniere gerade mit dem Pannendienst.
Auf der Autobahn gibt es einen Stau.
Alle Autos müssen warten.
Wie findest du Elektroautos?
Singular: das Hemd
Plural: die Hemden
Zu einem Hemd trägt man meistens
eine Krawatte oder eine Fliege.
Es gibt rote Hemden, gelbe Hemden,
grüne Hemden und bunte Hemden.
Das hier oben ist der sogenannte Hemdkragen.
Heute ist wieder Waschtag.
Ich muss alle meine Hemden waschen.
Wann ist bei dir immer Waschtag?
Singular: die Nuss
Plural: die Nüsse
Immer wenn ich eine Kokosnuss
sehe, denke ich an die Karibik.
Es gibt harte Walnüsse, ungesalzene
Erdnüsse und karibische Kokosnüsse.
Guck mal, das Eichhörnchen hat
eine leckere Nuss gefunden.
Manche Nüsse sind von einer Schale umgeben.
Welche Nüsse isst du am liebsten?
Singular: das Foto
Plural: die Fotos
Der Tourist macht im Urlaub ein
Foto mit seinem Fotoapparat.
Bei uns zu Hause hängen viele
schöne Fotos an der Wand.
Guck mal auf diesem Foto hier,
ist unser Hund noch ganz klein.
Fotos helfen mir dabei, mich an
die Vergangenheit zu erinnern.
Hast du ein Lieblingsfoto aus der Vergangenheit?
Singular: der Apfel
Plural: die Äpfel
Mein Arzt sagt, ich soll
jeden Tag einen Apfel essen.
Die roten Äpfel schmecken mir
eindeutig besser, als die grünen Äpfel.
Hm, esse ich lieber einen Apfel,
eine Birne, oder eine Banane?
In diesem Korb sind viele köstliche
Äpfel aus meinem Garten.
Isst du auch täglich einen Apfel?
Singular: der Lehrer
Plural: die Lehrer
Die Lehrerin für Physik ist die Physiklehrerin.
Im "Lehrerzimmer" bereiten sich
die Lehrer auf den Unterricht vor.
Ein guter Lehrer ist beim
Deutschlernen sehr wichtig.
Viele Lehrer unterrichten an einem
Gymnasium oder an einer Grundschule.
Wärst du auch gerne ein Lehrer?
Singular: der Stift
Plural: die Stifte
Zum Schreiben benutze ich
immer gerne einen blauen Stift.
Ich habe verschiedene Stifte in
unterschiedlichen Farben zur Auswahl.
Wenn ich unsicher bin, dann schreibe
ich meistens mit dem Bleistift.
Bunte Stifte zum Malen nennt man Buntstifte.
Besitzt du eigentlich einen Lieblingsstift?
Singular: die Vase
Plural: die Vasen
Die Vase für die Blumen nennt man Blumenvase.
Ich habe viele bunte Blumenvasen zu Hause.
Die Sonnenblumen stehen in der Vase.
Die Tulpen stehen in einer edlen Design-Vase.
Hast du auch eine Blumenvase zu Hause?
Tipp: Lerne die Vokabeln in der
Einzahl und in der Mehrzahl.